it is the last day of III 2016 my name
is Jake I'm here with Alex and we just
played some Gwent yeah we did go into
it's pretty cool so for the uninitiated
Gwent is a game you can play in The
Witcher 3 and they're making a
standalone game something that I've
wanted for a long time what did you
think of it
so the Gwent game is now it's a
multiplayer game so you can actually
play against other people which is
something that's been pretty requested
because it's going to awesome and
thousands of emails apparently yes mails
to get its own game right so when you're
playing against someone it's pretty much
like the Gwent in the game with like in
The Witcher 3 with some cool animations
and new art and stuff but what I thought
was super interesting is that they're
not just making it like a hearthstone
clone they're actually putting in this
really robust the single-player with a
whole bunch of campaigns that they say
this is it gonna be four of them they're
all gonna be ten plus hours long it
looks really cool yes so there's one for
each of the four factions and you're
probably wondering for isn't there five
now one of them didn't make it which one
was it
so that was the nilfgaardian faction and
they actually told me specifically they
are planning to bring it at some point
it they're still working on balance it's
it's gonna come a ways down the road
yeah it's too overpowered I think is
kind of what they were saying exactly so
I actually think one of the most
interesting parts about this game is
that there's this open world overworld
like you actually take control of a
character and walk around it's sort of
top-down in the in the presentation I
saw you're playing as Geralt and you
walk around and through this world you
can find different events to do and
encounters to explore and you get cards
from that actually which is kind of cool
it's kind of like what was in The
Witcher 3 with finding grain Carcassonne
of the world yeah and apparently you
you're not just Geralt throughout this
game you can be different characters I'm
guessing it depends on which faction you
choose yeah and each faction has its own
leader which is the like the leader card
and Gwent and that leader they told me
the story's going to be more like that
leader going through the world and
building up an army and so the Gwent
cards really are your soldiers in that
army and they all have personalities and
they all have dialogue and it's all
fully voiced it looks beautiful and it
looks super interesting as well one
thing that I was kind of concerned about
was that in The Witcher 3 by the end of
the game you become overpowered you have
pretty much all the cards you need to
win
how are they gonna balance this for the
game so when I played it seemed like it
was definitely more balanced but still
like right it seems like it's gonna be
tougher how does it differ in the main
game the single-player side is
completely separate from the competitive
multiplayer side so you're building your
deck through the single-player
differently than you are in the
competitive multiplayer side and they
didn't really talk much about how
they're gonna balance the single-player
side but it made it sound like like
things will scale with you as your army
becomes bigger than you'll encounter
better armies you know that's sort of
things so and then they can put a
multiplayer side obviously they're
balancing that like a you know
competitive collectible collectible card
game great so that's Gwent you can pick
it up in September and the beta should
be available soon as write some of beta
is in September the beta is in September
Xbox one and PC and the ps4 one is
coming later and for more on III 2016
make sure to stay tuned to games but see
you soon
you